so what's like your first memory like
the farthest back that you can remember
for me I was five it was the first day
of school and my teacher was taking
attendance I'm gonna raise my hands so
straight and say bye Dave out loud with
a clear voice and she will like me and I
will be good at school and then I
snapped out of my reverie only to
realize that she's been saying is there
an Anna Akana here it reminds me of how
like when you're meeting someone for the
first time and you're going to shake
hands and you're thinking about how
you're gonna tell them your name and
then you realize that they just said
their name and you missed it
because you were busy thinking about how
you're gonna say your own name that is
the life that is a metaphor for life cuz
wasn't it just yesterday that we were
all kids playing dress-up and tag and
cops and robbers and shit let them
niggas AG ah I heard it's a penis oh I
feel like I just saw Toy Story 1 in
theaters we know you can talk we saw the
movie you can't fool us anymore
top Tok Tok and it wasn't I just in high
school you guys are such good friends
Who am I kidding I don't have real
friends we're just in her head I don't
know I've just kind of been thinking a
lot this week about when will feel grown
up and will we ever feel grown up and do
we want to feel grown up because I mean
I don't know about you but I want to be
really young at heart when I'm in my 60s
and I want to hold on to that childlike
sense of wonder that we view the world
with as we grow into adulthood ah that's
a big zigga zagga but I will see you
next Monday
oh um I am doing book reviews now so if
that's something you're interested in
I'll put the links in the description
bar you know just kind of talking about
books as I go along and hopefully get
some good recommendations out like yeah
and I get Congress a haircut and he
looks like a rat cuz I did a horrible
fucking job he's so mad at me
well I will see you on Monday stay
awesome Gotham thanks good